So, this is going to lead us to
the concept of expectation maximization. So, expectation
maximization is actually, at an algorithmic level,
it's surprisingly similar to K means. So, what
we are going to do is, we're going to
tick-tock back and forth between 2 different
probabilistic calculations. So, you see that? I
kind of drew it like the other one.
>> Mm Hm. The names of the 2 phases are expectation,
and maximization. Sort of you know, our name is our algorithim.
>> I like that.
>> So, what they're going to do is, we're going to
move back and forth between a soft clustering, and computing
the means from the soft cluster. So the soft
clustering goes like this. This probablisitic indicator variable, Z I
J. Represents the likelihood that data element I comes
from cluster J. And so, the way we're going to do
that, since we're in the maximum likelihood setting, is to
use Bayes' rule, and say, well, that's going to be proportional
to the probability that data element I was
produced by cluster J. And then we have a
normalization factor. Normally, we'd also have the prior
in there. So why is the prior gone Charles?
>> Well, because you said it was the maximum likelihood. Scenario.
>> Yeah, right. We talked about how that
just meant that it was uniform and that
allowed us to just leave that component out.
It's not going to have any impact on the normalization.
>> Right.
>> So that's what the Z step is. Is if we had
the clusters, if we knew where the means were, then we could compute
how likely it is that the data would come from
the means, and that's just this calculation here. So that's computing
the expectation. Defining the Z varaibles from the muse. The centers.
We're going to pass that information. That clustering information, Z, over to
the maximization step. What the maximization is going to say is,
okay, well if that's the clustering, we can compute the means
from those clusters. All we have to do is just take
the average variable value. Right? So the average of the Xi's.
Within each cluster J. What's the likelihood it came from cluster J and
then again, we have to normalize. If you think of this as being
a 0 1 indicator variable, then really it is just the average of
the things we assign to that cluster. But here, we actually are kind
of soft assigning, so we could have half of one of the data
points in there, and it only counts half towards the average, and we
could have a tenth in another place, and a whole value in another
place, and so we're just doing this weighted average of the data points.
>> So,
can I ask you a question, Michael?
>> Yeah, shoot.
>> So, this makes sense to me, and I, and I
even get that for the Gaussian case, the z i variable will
always be non 0 in the end, because there's always some
probability. They come from some Gaussian because they have infinite extent. So
I, this all makes sense to me. Is there a way
to take exactly this algorithm and turn it into k means? I'm
staring at it, and it feels like if all your probabilities
were ones and zeroes, you would end up with exactly k means.
I think.
>> I dunno, I never really thought about that. Let's
think about that for a moment. Certainly, the case, if
all the z variables were 0, 1, then the maximization
set would be the means, which is what k means does.
>> Mm-hm. Then, what would happen? We send these means back, and what we do
in k-means is we say, each data point belongs to it's closest center.
>> Mm-hm.
>> Which is very similar actually to what this does. Except that
here we then make it proportional. So I guess it would
exactly that if we made these clustering assignments, pushed them to
0 or 1 depending on which was the most likely cluster.
Right, so if you made it so that the probability of you
being to a cluster actually depends upon all the clusters, and
you always got a 1 over 0. Basically you did, this was
like a hidden argmax kind of a thing, or a
hidden max or something. Then you would end up with exactly k-means.
>> I think
you're right.
>> Huh.
>> Yeah, I never thought about that.
>> Okay.
>> So it really does end up being an awful lot like
the k-means algorithm, which is improving
in the error metric, this squared error
metric. This is actually going to be improving in a probabilistic metric, right.
The, the data is going to be more and more likely over time.
>> That makes sense.